Now let's review treatments from the Biological Approach. First, we have drug
therapy. Remember that with the development of the Neuroleptics or
Antipsychotics, we found effective treatments for people with Schizophrenia.
Recall that the drugs were the Phenothiazines, including Chlorpromazine. And
that Chlorpromazine reduced the positive symptoms associated with
Schizophrenia. Such as the delusions, and the hallucinations. We call also that
we have three classes of drugs that have been used to treat depression. And
those are the MAO Inhibitors, the tricylics, and the SSRIs, Selective Serotonin
Reuptake Inhibitors. These have all been proven to be effective in the
treatment of depression, And we also discussed that the SSRIs are used to treat
anxiety as well. We also mentioned briefly that the tricyclics are sometimes
used for treating chronic pain, and for bedwetting, and also for the treatment
of ADHD. In addition, we discussed the use of both the benzodiazepines, and the
barbiturates, in the treatment of anxiety. But that the benzodiazepines are
preferred over the barbiturates, because they are safer. We also discussed the
long term negative consequences of using the benzodiazapines as they are
cognitive inhibitors. Also, you read about Lithium and that it's been
prescribed for a long time, because of it's ability to stabilize the mania
associated with Bipolar Disorder. And we also have the stimulants. The
stimulants help improve a person's ability to concentrate. And recall that,
also, from the biological approach are the pyschosurgeries that we discussed.
Briefly, you'll recall that we talked about the Prefrontal Lobotomy and that it
produce tragic effects and is no longer in use today. So this material here is
for a historical perspective, to see how far we've actually come in the area of
psychology. So lobotomy, remember, is not used today. We also discussed
Electroconvulsive therapy, or ECT, and it's used in the treatment of major
depressive disorder. Recall here that an electric current is passed through the
persons brain in order to induce a seizure. And afterwards, people report an
absence of their depression symptoms. And finally we discussed Repetitive
Transcranial Magnetic Stimulation, also for the treatment of depression. So
together, for the biological approach, we had our drug therapies as well as our
psychosurgeries.